should the vote for US president have to
boil down to choosing the lesser of two
evils because that's how a lot of
Americans feel about a possible contest
between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
come November you laugh but that viral
meme is capturing a real sentiment
Clinton and Trump are both more strongly
disliked than any nominee at this point
in the past 10 presidential cycles
its back most people say they're only
voting to make sure the opposing
candidate doesn't win 57% of people who
say they'll cast their ballots for Trump
are doing it just to make sure Hillary
loses on the other side 51 percent of
likely Clinton voters say they're voting
that way mainly the block Trump even
Clinton is positioning herself as the
least bad candidate on the day Trump
beat out of the public and opponents she
released this ad which only features
Republican leaders trash-talking their
now apparent nominee he's a race-baiting
xenophobic religious bigot
Clinton's got our own host of issues
although she's ahead she's still finding
it difficult to lock up the nomination
critics slam her close ties to Wall
Street
one of us has raised from Wall Street
her hawkish foreign policy and the fact
that her public record hasn't always
been very progressive you think New York
State should recognize gay marriage know
that perception isn't helped by the fact
that her camp is now targeting Bush
donors saying Clinton represents
moderate Republican values more than
Trump or that conservative billionaire
Charles Koch said there's a chance he
might support Clinton or that many
Republicans are coming out and staying
veiled vote for her over Trump as one
conservative described the dilemma
Hillary is preferable to Trump just like
malaria is preferable to Ebola the same
things that turned many liberals and
independents off Trump have also turned
off many conservatives his bombastic
personality his vulgarity look at those
hands are they small
the seeming lack of respect for the
political process like to punch him in
the face I'll tell you while he's
definitely appealed to a segment of the
GOP that's fed up with the ruling elites
many Republican heavy rates are
horrified that this is now the face of
their parties in fact one recent poll
found that only 24% of voters have a
positive opinion of Trump so what does
it say about a political process that'll
likely end up seeing two of the
historically most disliked candidates
facing off in November is this the best
we can do